Glory.
I'm Devin,
thank you so much for having me.
It's a pleasure to be here,
especially since this is a topic that's near and dear to my heart.
And I know that you've listed a long list of accomplishments.
Um,
but certainly,
you know,
I,
I think,
uh,
we would dive somewhere in to that story later on.
So today,
uh,
we've spent about 50 or so minutes to talk about how you can recognize some of
the signs and symptoms of stress and also what's causing some of those issues
too.
We'll also talk about some of the ways you can try to hack these,
you know,
there's symptoms away,
so how to hack your mind,
your body,
your time,
and your social life too.
And also if you ever need any more power ups too for your hacking.
Um,
you know,
there's some lots of resources out there and I would just point to you pointing
to some of the more promising ones too.
I think that all of us have faced some sort or know somebody who has faced some
sort of,
um,
uh,
condition in the past,
whether it's stress to anxiety,
to complete panic attacks and breakdowns to,
and certainly I myself have had a share of them too.
Um,
I and also seeing folks who have been affected by these conditions,
seeing it,
seeing folks and seeing them recover and seeing them reach their goals has been
such a joy to me.
And being able to work with folks at other universities.
This is Dr. Gibson on technology issues,
on how we can use technology to boost access to mental health conditions.
And now being able to teach other physicians and other healthcare providers to
has been really important to me.
Um,
but I gotta say,
uh,
you 20 years ago you would not have found me,
you being able to muster up the courage to speak in front of a crowd like this
or um,
folks worldwide too.
Um,
I remember the times when I was in Soda Hall at Uc Berkeley where I was,
I was studying computer science at the time,
was very,
very,
um,
stressful and there was a pressure cooker time.
And so this is me with a bag of beans trying to,
trying to nosh on and a study and then in all of the books that we've had to,
you know,
go through this is just for one of four exams,
uh,
in medical school to,
and even on vacation times,
you know,
I'd be taking my books and trying to read through them.
So it was this always on culture,
right?
Um,
that was through school and no PR pervades work that has,
um,
really,
uh,
led to a lot of anxiety and stress that I faced myself too.
And a lot of it comes from this sort of inner critic voice,
this feeling that,
you know,
I could never be good enough.
There are all these negative thoughts that I've dealt with in the past.
Uh,
things like telling myself,
Gosh,
I wish I could get more done or I feel tired all the time.
I can't make a mistake,
I'm not good enough.
Um,
these are things that I,
I know I faced myself and other people,
uh,
face and those voices can,
be internalized and lead to something called the imposter syndrome where you
feel like you're a fake or you're an imposter.
And I think that the turning point for me was seeing how much my colleagues were
suffering too.
Um,
I've,
I've learned just in the past few weeks that there's a physician who's who,
who,
uh,
takes their own life a day on average.
Um,
so this is being reported more and more,
um,
through suicide and,
and so the culture of medicine isn't set up to sort of acknowledge these mental
health conditions.
Um,
and the fact that there's just an enormous amount of stress.
the,
we see this in executives too,
and um,
administrators too.
There are warning signs such as depressed moon.
There've been cases of executives.
There's one in the Harvard Business Review.
One on one executive would say,
um,
I,
I wish I would have a heart attack so that could have an excuse to go to the
hospital and get away from work.
And,
uh,
that wasn't quite a suicidal plan.
But certainly along those lines,
if you,
if you're coming up with a plan and,
and thinking of executing on that plan,
that's a warning sign.
And then drugs and alcohol use,
uh,
to sort of mute those feelings can,
can be a warning sign that have more acute intervention as needed.
So having that,
uh,
and seeing that my colleagues,
seeing life in my family,
my nephews and nieces seeing,
um,
my,
uh,
relatives pass away.
And then finally I'm going through something big myself where I myself am being
considered and have found out that I'll be,
um,
be a live kidney donor.
Um,
they're,
you know,
potentially later this year.
That's a huge something that made me realize,
you know,
this is something that I would love to talk about and teach others about stress
and anxiety and making sure that,
um,
we live the life that we want to.
So what is the turning point that you or your friends may be facing to a online
people talk about things like kids being their turning point,
having kids or having a major health scare or traveling nonstop to the point of
exhaustion working nonstop.
Those are things that could be the turning point.
Um,
but you don't have to wait for a turning point to happen,
certainly,
but this is a big deal.
And as he,
as Devin had mentioned earlier too,
something that a lot of us,
especially men and especially in Southeast Asian cultures,
some cultures don't discuss this enough.
Um,
and instead I'm kind of just,
uh,
internalize it and not acknowledge that it exists in the past,
I think.
And maybe even the present to a thing that you're anxious or you're stressed.
Um,
you know,
people would be worried that they're being dramatic,
but it's not being dramatic.
There are huge,
there are numbers that back up the concept of other people's suffering from
anxiety and stress.
One in five people in the United States,
some sort of mental health condition in any given year.
And there've been a lot more statistics lately that have been released about how
anxiety and depression are some of the most common commonly reported conditions.
This one was in college campuses.
There was a New York Times article last year that talked about,
um,
how anxiety's a much bigger issue than we think it is.
Um,
and just this past week,
the American psychiatric association has been doing yearly reviews of anxiety
and they found that anxiety levels in the United States have been increasing,
um,
uh,
particularly around paying bills.
So their financial stressors.
And then just about five days ago,
um,
a study of folks in the U K a s showed that high job demands low sense of
control in jobs and a hijab strain,
uh,
has been predictive of future onset of common mental health conditions.
Basically depression and anxiety too.
So this is something that a lot of us are facing too.
And if we don't take address,
these issues can lead to things like depression or low mood,
high,
high stress hormones,
cholesterol Epinephrin,
which boosts your high blood pressure in an unhealthy manner if it's too long
term poor coping skills.
And burnout as well.
So there are a lot of different flavors of stress and there are lot of symptoms
that can manifest itself.
Um,
but in general I would say that,
um,
stress,
uh,
you know,
there are different flavors of stress.
Sometimes stress can be harnessed for good,
right?
If you don't have,
um,
some sort of deadline or if you don't have,
some sort of motivating factor,
it can be difficult to get things done,
right?
So there's,
there are two psychologists that Harvard that talked about performance and
correlating it with levels of stress.
And if you have too little amount of stress,
then you tend to be more bored and you tend to be too calm.
But if just the right amount of stress,
um,
or you stress,
you can achieve optimum performance,
you feel energized,
you feel focused,
work and feel like f can feel effortless or you might achieve that flow state.
But if you have too much stress,
then your performance can suffer.
This is something we call distress.
Where can lead to things like burnout,
fatigue,
exhaustion,
health issues too.
And burnout.
There are some components of burnout that can,
uh,
inform you whether,
you know,
you may be at risk to exhaustion,
cynicism and feeling like you nothing's really mattering and that,
and feeling like your work doesn't matter.
So exhaustion can include feelings of negativity.
You can't concentrate,
you're just kind of emotionally fatigued,
um,
and feeling incompetent.
That especially occurs if you don't have enough resources or if you don't have
clear expectations are you don't have good relationships with your coworkers or
your family.
Uh,
and cynicism to feeling detached and negative feeling like it doesn't matter.
So combinations of these can lead to,
um,
can be a sign of burnout and stress.
This especially happens if you just happened to be a workaholic.
So I remember going through college that helped me go plow through a lot of
exams.
But then,
uh,
that's it to the point.
Sometimes people get this to an unhealthy state where they're working
excessively because things don't meet their standards.
Things aren't perfect enough.
There's also a different type of perfectionism where you just completely avoid
doing work and you end up procrastinating and avoiding touching,
touching that I'm inbox because you know that you can't get through inbox zero.
So it's very fascinating to learn about this.
Um,
this perfectionism and there are ways to address this as well.
When we see folks in clinic,
um,
uh,
we tried to come up with some sort of,
um,
thought of as to what may be going on and what symptoms maybe closely matching
to a particular diagnosis.
And that just helps us sort of find the best sort of ways to treat these
conditions.
Generalized anxiety is one of them.
And generalized anxiety is when you feel like you're on edge almost.
Uh,
uh,
most of the time if you are maybe nervous or you can't control the worries,
you may feel like it is difficult to concentrate or you may be easily fatigued
to.
Um,
and that tends to happen with throughout the day.
So that's sort of anxiety throughout the day.
And then some folks have panic attacks where the anxiety spikes within just a
few minutes.
They feel like they're short of breath,
their heart rate goes up there shaking,
there's they're sweating.
I've seen this in classmates and a co Co colleagues as well.
And this can get to the point where you have maybe multiple panic attacks a day
and then you avoid things like driving because you don't know if you can drive
in a car without getting a panic attack.
Some people have posttraumatic stress disorder and that's when you're exposed to
something that is life threatening or very traumatic.
And then afterwards how you react to that stress,
um,
can,
uh,
determine whether you're able to function normally at work and at school and at
home too.
So I've seen folks with major trauma in their lives,
but they're able to brush it off just fine.
They don't think about it,
they don't get nightmares.
And then I see others who tell me that they faced a major trauma.
They get nightmares at night or maybe daytime nightmares or flashbacks.
Um,
and they don't realize they have PTSD.
So this is something that I think is important to recognize in our peers and
our,
our ourselves too.
If this is something that we face growing up there,
just obsessive compulsive disorder where you,
you,
you can't get rid of thoughts,
uh,
they just keep on coming up in your mind.
You know,
that they're not realistic,
but you got to figure out a way to get rid of them.
And then there are components where you're doing things over and over again,
like washing your hands for a long period of time just to sort of feel better.
Or maybe you're checking locks for like an hour a day gets to the point where it
interferes with your life too.
So that's OCD,
that's another type of anxiety.
Um,
so there's also addiction to where you take,
um,
substances and alcohol,
and they have all sorts of different drugs that can cause different reactions.
Bottom line is that this is a brain disease.
Uh,
and this is where,
um,
folks may have an addiction and they may use it even though they know full well
that it's harmful to.
So this addiction,
the good news is that there's ways to treat this,
uh,
sort of this brain condition.
Um,
but it certainly recognizing it is an important first step.
So you may have seen questionnaires online that talk about,
you know,
do you mind my,
you have burnout or might you have depression?
And one of the questionnaires we have is the Phq nine patient health
questionnaire with nine questions.
Um,
but this one is particularly for depression,
but there are all these issues that occur with the Phq nine and wouldn't you
know,
it,
we have a whole manual called the diagnostic and statistical manual of mental
disorders that tries to help us diagnose and recognize these symptoms.
But realistically what we tried to do is look at the whole picture,
someone's whole life and,
and the two inch book doesn't cover all of the possibilities sometimes.
So this is why I like to call what we've called the thousand cuts.
You know,
sometimes people are wounded by a thousand cuts.
Um,
so he might need,
um,
quite a few bandaids for those cuts.
Uh,
so recognizing those external drivers,
all of these external things that can cause anxiety and stress is important.
And so that way you can know what the problem is.
And then you can hack it if you need to.
So this is me in an outpatient clinic.
I remember one of the folks that I came that came to see me,
um,
actually was having,
was very,
very stressed out.
Well what,
what kind of stress?
Where are they facing?
They,
they were actually,
he,
he was actually hearing voices that weren't really there.
Uh,
and it was because we had to ask,
you know,
how long has this been going on?
And he said,
well,
you know,
he hasn't been sleeping for a while.
Sleep affects your daytime performance,
your mood and your anxiety,
and that also in turn affects your sleep.
So we try to address the sleep first,
try to address the hallucinations that they're having.
Next time they came into clinic,
they came to see me and he said he still having them.
Um,
and I asked,
I dive deeper.
Why are they,
why were they anxious about why,
why,
why were they,
uh,
not be able to sleep?
Actually,
I gave the punchline and I'm already,
they would turn up.
They were very anxious.
What were they anxious about?
They were actually anxious about work turned out that they couldn't concentrate,
they couldn't focus at work,
they couldn't get the things done.
They were about to be laid off or fired.
Um,
and in talking with them further and digging deeper into these details,
found out that for their whole life he had been suffering through Adhd,
actually not knowing,
not knowing the exact diagnosis or,
and that it was treatable.
So we treated the Adhd and the next time they came to the clinic was the
commerce I've ever seen,
um,
seen him.
And he was able to actually function quite well at work and be able to be able
to sleep at night too,
just because we were able to dive deep into his details,
keeping on asking why is it this way?
Why is it this way?
And instead of just looking at the surface,
so knowing all of these things is important and we try to combine epidemiology,
all these statistics,
one in five that that affects a lot of us in this room.
That doesn't quite help.
So we have to dive deeper into the details.
What if it's a cultural issue?
If you are Southeast Asian for instance,
um,
you know,
could there be an issue such as coming from a family with,
um,
who immigrated from a war torn country?
Could that be a cultural issue?
So we try to combine this into some sort of framework.
Um,
so for instance,
one particular framework is the bylaw bio psychosocial model where we look at
the biology,
the psychology and the social factors that make up someone's someone,
um,
and informed them on how,
how they behave or factors such as where's your family from was their trauma in
their family.
And you know,
what,
how do they react to adverse adversity?
Um,
do they have enough resilience to carry them through the day?
So we look at things like this through the lens of,
uh,
even say culture and religion to Southeast Asians for instance,
have a lot of ingrained elements of religion into their culture,
like Confucianism and Buddhism that may prevent them from seeking help that they
need.
And I mentioning this because I've done work amongst multiple Asian,
southeast Asian cultures.
Um,
things like accepting suffering too can be a major issue too,
when they're,
when you're trying to help somebody and they're not telling you exactly or
they're not filling the questionnaire out.
Correct.
You know,
to reflect their own internal reality.
Um,
things like,
um,
external PR.
So not just the internal pressures by external pressures and society's
expectations of them.
So for instance,
in South East Asian cultures,
there's an enormous pressure to perform,
to be perfect,
to be that sort of Wiz kid that's being talked about in popular press,
like Time magazine.
Um,
and,
uh,
and can you achieve success or are,
is there something that's preventing you from achieving that success?
Um,
so recognizing as important.
and there are all sorts of other things to recognize that even within
subcultures too,
you can't always assume that there's a blanket sort of stereotype.
So for instance,
um,
among particular populations,
some Southeast Asian cultures don't finish high school.
There had been a large number of foreclosures during the great recession,
longterm unemployment that can affect,
um,
particular subgroups.
Um,
you know,
uh,
in the United States,
environmental factors can be an issue.
If you've been exposed to a lot of trauma,
violence and neglect,
abuse or poverty can make put you at higher risk.
The things that happen or don't happen in childhood,
the number of parents,
the amount of time your parents were around,
how much family were around medical conditions too and abuse to um,
or our school issues,
teacher issues,
um,
and bullies as well too can also inform the way you react to adverse events,
to relationships.
This can be a sensitive subject.
Things like interpersonal violence and how unstable or stable relationship is
and whether you're supported or unsupported through your preferences and your
desire for a relationship can be a factor.
And then finally,
um,
two other things by biology can be something that can be an issue.
So medical conditions,
the way your brain is set up,
the way your brain is structured too.
If there's any sort of trauma that had happened,
physical trauma to happen to the brain,
thyroid conditions,
a lot of things can cause anxiety and stress.
Even the medicines that we take can come with some,
some of side effects as well.
Um,
and you know how the Amygdala to is structured,
the Amygdala is the emotional center of the brain up here that processes all
these sensory inputs.
And if it senses any sort of things that it perceives as a threat,
it can cause all these things to happen.
Your body and increased heart rate,
increased blood pressure,
you might be on edge a lot.
Um,
you might freeze to and you might not be thinking correctly.
So just imagine if you had a lot of sort of stressful situations at work and
you're constantly on edge,
you're ag Migdal,
that would be,
um,
you know,
on fire all the time too.
So being able to handle this is important too,
as well as the psychology and how you,
how you react and how you behave too.
So for instance,
there are some personality factors such as self esteem,
which we talked about earlier.
Things like how,
how well you deal with stress and,
uh,
if you're a generally pessimistic to that can affect the way that you behave
too.
So that's why I think that,
um,
you know,
there isn't a magic bullet treatment right now.
There are all these things that you can address and knowing which knobs,
which buttons to push and which things to adjust can be helpful and important in
your life if you're trying to sort of reduce your anxiety and reduce your
stress.
So the hacks,
right?
Um,
I think of this in terms of you know,
computer programming.
Um,
when you're trying to program something or some sort of large structure,
there's multiple ways of doing this.
You might be doing this in an iterative fashion,
right?
Cause you're continuously changing.
The code are continuously improving the product to um,
programming.
There is no one magic solution.
If you go to stack overflow and you're trying to find the answers to your
question,
there are many different ways to,
to hack that python script for instance.
Um,
it's uh,
you have to research this,
you have to implement,
test it in your life too and deploy.
And if some of you are in sales or management a more,
it's sometimes difficult to understand,
okay,
how am I going to achieve that milestone or get that deliverable when there are
all these other market conditions,
new regulations in DC.
And around the world that can be changing the way you practice.
Um,
um,
and um,
developing your product.
So therefore,
particular hacks,
you know,
that,
uh,
I'd like to go over this is just a menu of different ways you can address some
of those conditions earlier.
Um,
and so you can cherry pick the ones that you think will work for you.
Try One a week or try one every two weeks to see if it works.
We're going to talk about hacking your mind,
hacking your body,
hacking your time,
and hacking your social life.
And of course,
there's all these other ways you can hack the rest of your life,
hacking your transportation or hacking your sleep too.
But first,
hacking your mind,
how you think,
how you feel and how you act,
um,
can be helpful when you're dealing with stress and anxiety.
So,
uh,
out,
I think I had alluded this,
alluded to this earlier to anxiety is something I definitely face,
uh,
myself.
Um,
feeling like,
oh,
I got to do something and feeling a little nervous,
right?
Um,
and 20 years ago,
again,
being in front of a crowd,
um,
and talking,
was quite nerve wracking.
So I did something,
I did some,
a series of experiments over the past,
uh,
um,
you know,
throughout my life,
exposing myself to stress and exposing myself to be little bits of stress
initially and go and getting larger and larger each time.
I remember teaching a python helps session.
This wasn't sorta har teaching of Aaron and some other folks from the computer
science undergraduate association and teaching a small group of undergraduates
teaching,
um,
and toastmasters.
So while I was a software engineer,
I was,
I joined other folks from the engineering,
uh,
engineering teams to,
um,
join toastmasters,
which is a group of peers who help each other out in terms of improving public
speaking to,
and then from there I was able to,
uh,
handle sensitive conversations,
so to speak,
not just speaking in public,
but speaking with sensitive,
um,
people speaking in under sensitive conditions with families in the surgical Icu
and then the psychiatric intensive care unit speaking in a business setting.
So I attended,
I think I told Gloria this,
I spoke with specifically joined a business school because I wanted to learn how
to speak in front of a professional crowd,
uh,
and,
and learning how to handle an advocate for,
um,
projects,
uh,
in front of a professional crowd.
And then this went on to hackathons.
Um,
and,
uh,
learning how to pitch for instance was very helpful,
was very helpful.
This was my exposure therapy.
Um,
and other people do this too,
if you have any particular fears.
Uh,
and so fear of heights,
fear of enclosed spaces,
that's where exposure therapy can be very helpful.
There's another type of therapy that's been very helpful.
Um,
and that's where you'd kind of delete any sort of negative self talk or delete
any sort of negative behaviors and their particular ways to do this.
And the most common form is through something called cognitive behavioral
therapy or CBT.
And CBT is basically where you take your thoughts,
your cognitions and your thoughts informed the way you feel and how you feel
informs the way you behave or informs the,
uh,
issue.
And so these sort of our effect each other and how you changed your behavior or
how you change your thoughts can affect how you feel.
So if we were trying to adjust the behavior,
identifying the behavior,
then decreasing the negative and increasing the positive aspects can,
is something that you can coach yourself to do.
So for instance,
if you feel bad or you feel angry,
um,
or down because they were trying to find a job or trying to find a new project,
you might be telling yourself,
I'm never going to get the job and you feel bad at or about it,
then it may actually discourage you and you start trying to apply for jobs.
If you are,
say,
having a difficult time with a coworker,
a during a sensitive meeting and you,
you might think,
oh gosh,
my colleague hates me,
then you might feel angry about this.
You might blame them and they might end up giving them the cold shoulder.
Or you might be in front of a large audience and you might say,
oh,
my talk at Google is going to fail.
Uh,
and you might feel scared.
And then you might end up avoiding public speaking entirely.
And so the key thing here is the avoidance avoidance.
And the uh,
is something that you want to address.
You want to change the behavior because a little bit of stress is a good thing.
Um,
the stresses and the issues that the behavior and how you react to it.
Now there are some positive,
um,
positive self talk that you want to promote.
So if you know,
hey,
I'm a,
I'm a pretty decent coder,
I can,
I can hack this code,
you know,
you might feel good about it.
That might encourage you to do more check ins or take on more projects.
And,
and so this is the kind of thing you want to promote to a,
in your own,
um,
your own loops to use a watch Westworld reference.
Um,
so there's,
uh,
there's another way to address this,
you know,
with the thoughts to you can change your thoughts.
And so if just the behavior,
but thinking about the thoughts,
um,
oftentimes,
you know,
I just used that catastrophic example of,
oh gosh,
this Google talk is talk at Google is going to fail a massively and people are
going to point at me and laugh at me and that's a catastrophe.
That's the worst case scenario we can think of.
So train yourself to think about other scenarios that could happen can be
helpful.
Um,
and uh,
we use this in decision analysis in,
in the business world.
Um,
so thinking about the best case scenario or the best case is getting to reach as
many people as possible,
helping them out and everyone's anxiety and stress goes away.
That'll be awesome,
right?
What is the most likely scenario?
Well,
maybe some place in between.
So this sort of technique can be helpful in modulating a modular and your
expectations in your,
and catastrophic thinking too.
So you can try this yourself.
There are a lot of books out there about cognitive behavioral therapy.
There are also apps,
audio books and guides.
And if you do see a therapist,
you know,
can find one that specifically addresses cognitive behavioral therapy to being
present in the moment,
it can be also helpful too.
Um,
so these are some worksheets you can get.
Uh,
online to being present in the moment can be helpful.
Um,
because a lot of anxiety is just dwelling on the future,
being worried about what the future holds,
thinking about all the bad things that could happen.
Eckhart Tolle wrote in the power of now that all negativity is caused by,
um,
can be caused by denial of the presence.
So not focusing on the present,
but being worried about too much of the future and not enough of the present
moment.
So there are ways to introduce that presence in your life.
For instance,
mindfulness meditation may have heard these terms,
um,
talked about a lot.
There are lots of different ways to go about it.
Mindfulness is where you're aware of things outside your body of the external.
Um,
your senses are alive.
So for instance,
you may be focused on the present moment of your environment,
the sounds in the room.
Um,
breathing,
breathing to meditation is where you try to decrease the mental chatter,
the monkey mind,
Nicole and Buddhism,
and allowing the thoughts that you,
that pop up in your mind to float by like clouds.
And so this has been very,
uh,
very prevalent,
especially in entrepreneurial entrepreneurs and CEOs who,
um,
who want to sort of achieve that focus.
So this is one particular hack.
Self acceptance is something that's also important to living in the present
moment requires that you accept the way you are at the moment and,
and,
uh,
not be a doormat and not let other people walk over you.
Um,
I myself had the sheds in the past where I felt like I should be working on this
website or I should be working on this research project and I've been taught
that a few sources I shouldn't should on myself.
Um,
accepting your anxiety and stress to and accepting that,
hey,
there's anxiety.
Um,
what can you do about this?
And not letting it define you can be helpful in your journey towards self
acceptance.
And then gratitude.
Practicing gratitude can help you reframe negative thoughts and be in and sort
of that cycle of negativity and allow you to think about what's positive in your
life.
For instance,
each day you could think about three things that you're grateful for,
whether it's a coworker or whether it's one particular aspect of your work or
even yourself to are there particular things that you're grateful for,
um,
that,
uh,
that you can appreciate.
Storing it somewhere and reviewing it at,
during stressful times can be very helpful to,
um,
so that when you're feeling down,
then you can look back and see,
uh,
the things that you're grateful for.
And I've been able to use this in my own practice.
And then finally,
during stressful situations there techniques like the freeze frame technique
where if you're in the moment of acute anxiety or anger,
um,
you've just be able to recognize that moment.
Try to step away from that moment focused on breathing so that you can separate
yourself from that stressful moment.
You can think about a body particular body part or the heart and then trying to
think of a positive feeling.
And then reflecting on whether you can change the scenario,
is there a better alternative towards thinking and more constructive alternative
towards thinking that way?
So this is something that will require some practice I think.
But um,
certainly,
um,
this has been talked about in the business literature,
in the Harvard Business Review on stress.
Um,
and final,
uh,
final note.
Um,
you know,
a lot of the techniques,
um,
can be difficult to remember.
I think if you are,
there's all these different techniques that are out there,
all these different hacks,
sometimes apps can be helpful.
This is something that we've been looking at at the American psychiatric
association and I definitely don't want to say I endorse any of them,
but you can just try them out of these are low cost sort of ways to sort of
achieve,
um,
you know,
implement these in your life too.
I think that,
um,
what's exciting too is hacking your body can be helpful to your body and your
mind are intertwined.
And it's fascinating because I found that,
um,
uh,
making sure that I treat myself well,
and practice self care is important.
And I actually gained clarity and I got to say even a year ago,
um,
my,
I wasn't this,
I really wasn't this way a year ago.
I had a BMI or body mass index over 30,
so I was considered medically obese.
And it wasn't until I learned about all of these health issues in my family.
Um,
and then potential surgery coming up that I realized that I needed to act on
this and sort of work on cutting down my obese,
my obesity.
So I looked at two things,
diet and exercise.
But how you do it,
there's so many different hacks and ways to achieve that.
And I think that,
um,
you know,
the ones that seem to have helped the most is focusing on more of a
Mediterranean diet.
Uh,
this,
this particular one is where you're focusing on more whole grains,
foods,
plant based foods instead of the more Western Diet Starches,
fried foods and sort of processed foods too.
And in the scientific literature we're seeing more that following these diets
can be helpful in reducing your risk of depression and reducing your risk of a
feeling down.
Um,
when we're looking at things like fiber to having a high fiber content can
increase and can decrease your odds of getting depression and also,
um,
helping out with your gut bacteria.
And we're finding out more and more that,
um,
the fiber in food and plants can help promote healthy,
uh,
colonies of bacteria to grow within your gastrointestinal tract to fiber.
And then also probiotics.
A lot of folks are making a big deal out of this.
I think that the studies aren't really,
um,
uh,
for anxiety and depression are more in rat models and mouse models.
But certainly there's a lot of claims out there right now.
They're saying that probiotics should be nicknamed a psychobiotics because they
do change the way we think.
We already know that they can lower fasting glucose and decrease blood pressure.
Uh,
and again,
in mass models it does reduce anxiety and depression related behaviors.
So it's spawning a whole new area of research,
uh,
about the gut and the brain and seeing how these,
what we,
what we eat and how we treat our gut can affect the way our brain functions
through,
uh,
metabolites through neurotransmitters like serotonin through bacterial
molecules.
So it's very interesting.
Um,
this particular physician and Columbia University has been talking about
nutritional psychiatry,
a nutritional mental health and how it can affect your mood.
And so he's been discussing the scientific literature behind,
uh,
eating right and having a better mood exercise.
Uh,
this is my,
uh,
futilely trying to use the elliptical.
Um,
and there are different ways to hack a exercise.
I've tried to do this by commuting,
by bicycle,
for instance.
Um,
both in southern California,
believe it or not,
and northern California.
Uh,
and finally I found that group exercise really helps me because my mirror now I
feel like my mirror neurons,
which are,
um,
this concept where you're sort of able to mimic other people and sort of feel
what other people are feeling.
Uh,
our most active because I feel like exercising when other people around me are
exercising too.
So I've been able to,
I've been fortunate enough to use,
uh,
apps with Google,
Google fit,
um,
on tracking my calories and tracking the nutrients and I've been able to see
results and I've lost 30 pounds,
which is awesome.
Over this past half year,
if I've noticed that,
um,
their rewards,
I've had to buy new clothes,
um,
my energy's higher,
I see results,
but I'm also,
uh,
I also have,
not just the rewards but also fear,
um,
of say upcoming,
uh,
upcoming surgery and societal expectations as well too.
So could you use that to harness yourself and motivate yourself to do more
productive behaviors?
Yes,
it's kind of Nice as a kind of a negative thought,
but it's been helpful for me too.
So hacking your body,
hacking your mind.
How about hacking your time?
Time is something that's really precious to us and it's interesting to see,
um,
a lot of business articles about this.
But one of the most,
uh,
most salient quotes I think is from this speaker who also spoke at talks by
Google or I mean Satie who's a New York Times bestselling author.
He says that,
show me a man's calendar and spending and I'll show you what he prioritizes.
So show me your time,
show me your,
how you spend your money,
and then it kind of shows you where your priorities lie.
So just imagine if you took your calendar and plotted out every single hour of
your day and ranking was,
was this productive and does it make me feel good?
Do I feel like I have a lot of energy or value from this hour that I spent two?
And I remember doing this even with my old devices.
This is shows you how old I am.
I used to someone,
the Palmer was,
I've been thinking about this for over a decade.
Uh,
this is the tap wave,
PDA.
And even,
uh,
I tried the most skin notebooks and printing calendars out to people have all
sorts of different ways of how they track their time.
But I think that the most fundamental thing,
um,
they,
you know,
the calendar's change.
I think you've deployed Google tasks and new version of Google tasks a week or
two ago.
Um,
which is exciting,
but every year,
every two years I think I'm finding myself using different tools.
But the bottom line is being able to take all the worries and all the anxiety
out of your head using an external brain and allowing that external brain to
deal of the worries is important.
And I think no one talks a better,
no one talks about this better than uh,
David Allen who talks about the art of stress free productivity and he actually
has an algorithm in his book and you can find this algorithm online too about
how you can get tasks,
get the words out of your head,
email,
etc.
And how to sort of a do it,
delegate it or defer it as he says as the actions and placing them into lists,
calendars and folders,
being able to worry about it,
letting something else worry about it and putting your anxieties somewhere else
can be very,
very helpful.
And then also controlling are focusing on your locus of control.
Um,
can be helpful and not on things outside your control.
So people have talked about things like the information diet and blocking off
things that they don't,
they can't control social media news sources instead checking them maybe even
once a day or even once a week.
Two to minimize that stressor to say no to Fomo can be a really difficult,
especially here in San Francisco.
I think there's so many different activities that happen every day.
And fomo if you're,
um,
if you,
uh,
if you don't know if you're,
um,
uh,
if the fear of missing out and being able to recognize the fear of missing out,
identifying if the or applies to social media or conference events.
If you're at a conference,
I mean,
I think some of you have had that where there are seven concurrent tracks going
on and you're,
you got to choose to and you know,
you don't know where to turn to and that can lead to a lot of fomo too.
So being able to recognize that Fomo,
setting limits,
setting boundaries too can be helpful.
So you set up.
So you tell yourself,
I will dedicate three hours to eight hours of just conference time and then I
deserve to have a two hour break or I deserve to have drinks with friends later
on too.
So thinking about those options and seeing what's most appealing to you and
being content with it can be helpful too,
especially in the work environment,
especially in the home environment.
Blocking off time for productive,
productive time to productively play is important so that you can sort of let
your mind wander,
get those Aha moments when you're in the shower or if you're on nature hikes to
sleep.
Blocking often enough time for sleep can be helpful too.
Um,
there's a whole art to hacking sleep that I talk about with my patients I treat
and trying to help them with their sleeping.
Um,
and then pets to,
um,
this particular
dog has helped my family as well,
uh,
with,
with our anxieties and stress levels.
And then finally,
um,
to looking at how you structure your time blocks to can be helpful.
Um,
the,
there's the pomodoro method.
This is something similar to the pomodoro method where you do a lot of hard work
and activity and then you take a break deliberately for say 10 minutes.
You just kind of check out,
relax,
surrender,
control that your mind wandered and then dive back in when you need to.
So some people use 10 minutes and people use whole night for sleep or showering.
Um,
that's protect one particular technique.
And there's a similar technique that I've used called the pomodoro technique,
um,
that,
that can help that help me sustain focus with a timer.
How can your social life is also one of the final hacks?
I will talk about how we can choose your tribe can be very important to,
um,
the thing I try to remind myself is now in our professional circles and our
personal circles,
you are the average of the five people you spend the most time with,
right?
You basically adopted the decision making habits of the people you hang out
with,
you,
um,
attain their knowledge.
We talk about strong ties and we ties in networking networks and social
networks.
And so these are the strong ties.
And how and who you choose can,
um,
can be helpful to your life too.
So you want to choose positive people who are givers and who are not takers.
There's a fascinating book by Adam Grant,
give and take that talks about how he's found people who are generous and how
they're able to focus on the greater good and how they're able to benefit people
in their network instead of people who just take things for themselves and sort
of use other people,
uh,
and walk over them like doormats.
And so being a giver can be helpful in setting the tone for the rest of the,
the,
your colleagues and your friends.
We also want to avoid burnout or bending over backwards too much and letting
other people use you to celebrating wins is important too.
And you know,
I think that this is something I don't see too much,
not used as much in the medical world because we're so,
so busy.
But I,
I've noticed that even in during stressful times,
leaders will reward people even with a simple thank you too.
Thank you.
I'm grateful to you for your work.
Uh,
can,
can really lift people's spirits and it's very,
very inexpensive.
Showing gratitude to yourself to celebrating who you are,
can and,
and,
and your strengths can help change the way you view yourself if you have self
esteem issues.
And then s and then trying to decrease destructive criticism and destructive
negative self talk.
Um,
what,
uh,
this has been helpful to me because,
um,
in,
in my line of work,
we make new best friends every two weeks.
So every two weeks there's a different project or there's a different hospital
or a different clinic that we go to.
Um,
think of them just like Pokemon.
Pokemon is where,
you know,
folks are able to collect and categorize and lay and find out strengths.
People strengthen their own.
Pokemon strength is so two,
you want to do this with anyone you meet,
uh,
any,
you know,
friends,
family.
Um,
and I've been able to adopt this system in my contacts list,
um,
tagging folks by location,
how I met them.
Because one of the biggest anxieties I have is when I meet someone again for the
second time or the third time,
I completely forget.
How did I meet them?
What did they like?
I,
you know,
I forget their names too.
Um,
so using these techniques can be helpful and there are whole books have been
written such as this one never eat alone by Keith Ferrazzi that talks about
these sort of hacks.
Um,
so lots of different hats.
We talked,
we've talked about,
I want to leave you with one final thought is that if,
uh,
there are so many different hacks out there is,
um,
a lot of fun actually to sort of figure out how you can boost yourself,
how you can make yourself feel better,
less anxious,
less stress.
And I'm glad to see that the mainstream media and mainstream blogs are talking
about these topics.
Buzzfeed,
for instance,
has talked about mental health issues,
business coaches.
This is one of my mentors and colleagues,
Preston knee,
who's talked about not just a east and west Asian American professionals,
but now he's looking at personality and how it informs communication,
uh,
with difficult people and narcissist to and professionals in my sphere of work
physicians,
which includes a psychiatrists,
psychologists,
social workers and marriage and family therapists are trained to listen,
uh,
in a nonjudgmental way and be able to offer guidance to help you navigate
through rough waters.
And,
uh,
there are,
there's medicines too.
If things get really severe,
you can do the one,
two punch.
I tell my,
uh,
the folks I,
I help out,
there's talk therapy and there's metacenter therapy.
There are pros and cons to each one and they all act in different lengths of
time too.
And so we're here to help you navigate those waters.
And then there are lots of different groups out there,
advocacy groups.
Um,
Naomi for instance,
this,
the national lines and mental illness,
but I want to highlight the anxiety and depression association of America,
Ada.
They've got some really cool charts on how you can figure out what kind of is
best.
Um,
and what kind of therapy you might like.
And they talk about things like,
um,
fomo and Ada and,
and uh,
also ADHD I believe too.
Um,
and then if you're interested in technology,
this is a,
we're here at Google.
Um,
there are a lot of technology events that are around mental health.
And so if you wanted to hack with us,
you can join us at the American psychiatric association.
The American telemedicine association has their own group.
And then the hackathon that we had met at Gloria Hack mental health,
they have an upcoming hackathon in early June two,
and it's very,
and it's a very easy to join too.
So we've talked about how we can cover the signs and symptoms and recognize them
and how we can hack different aspects of your life for your own mental wellbeing
and how you can power up.
But we just wanted to underscore how important it is for us to normalize this
and talk about the subject.
So if we're able to talk about this swap techniques,
share techniques,
and how we can improve our own lives and the lives of people around us,
that is,
that will be an amazing outcome I think for the,
so I'm happy to send a summary and some bonus material.
Um,
thank you for having me.
Thank you so much.
This is very informative.
I learned a lot and I'm going to be watching it again.
Um,
do we have any live questions?
Hi.
Uh,
I know that you talked about exposure therapy where you talked about kind of
exposing people to your triggers over time gradually and then to CBT where you
can delete or remove those triggers from,
from,
from your,
uh,
life.
Um,
how do you balance or where do you draw the line between like what to kind of
keep exposing yourself to and like what's,
what's a removed?
Sure.
So,
um,
I actually would say that CBT isn't exactly removing,
but sort of reframing the way you react to it.
So it's not entirely like you noticed that the stressor is still there.
Your coworker and colleague still exists.
We can't delete our colleagues,
our colleagues.
And then also we can't,
um,
we may might not be able to delete the actual issue,
but how we react to it,
uh,
is,
um,
the core change and we're trying to make with CBT and exposure therapy and
exposure therapy.
We're changing how we react to a stressor,
but we're not changing the stressor itself in CBT.
There is this something that's also stressful,
either the thought or the behavior.
Um,
uh,
and we just basically tried to change those are modulating.
So I think that that's,
uh,
that,
that's how I would reframe that.
Um,
can you speak about how you anticipate technology will support mental health
management over the next 10 years?
Um,
and how you think Google can help?
Sure.
You
already have had a fantastic,
phenomenal speaker.
I think Dr. Daniel Schlosser,
uh,
spoke at an earlier,
um,
uh,
meeting to on this subject to,
I think that,
um,
there are many different ways,
but I got to say technology is 20% of the 20% of the answer.
The rest of it's going to be politics and policies.
Um,
things like reimbursement,
how he can train your,
the,
um,
mental health leaders to,
to,
uh,
be able to,
to spread these technologies.
That's going to be an important aspect too.
So a lot of the technologies are already there.
We already have video conferencing where you already have apps,
you already have sort of activity trackers and smartwatches.
But how are we going to use that is going to be the next frontier.
Uh,
and so we're seeing a lot of activity in terms of research and dissemination.
So if,
if,
uh,
so partnering with folks like the Ucs,
psychiatry,
Digital Health Corp for instance,
um,
they are trying to,
uh,
work with researchers on getting digital health and digital technologies
implemented.
So I'd encourage you to look at the Ucf Psychiatry Digital Health Corp.
Thank you.